when we think of entrepreneurship and we
think of starting stuff we think how can
i be
innovative how can i be new in reality
in order to make a lot of money it's how
do i get locked into this
to to the point to where like it's gonna
be a pain in the ass to
go anywhere else
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right everyone we've got a good
episode we're going to talk about class
ring the class ring business shockingly
brings in close to a billion dollars a
year for a company that you might have
heard of but we're going to do a
breakdown of them
um what else is it we're going to talk
about stretching gyms i'm a huge fan of
paying 100
and going to the stretch lab we're going
to break that business down what else we
gonna talk about
we talk about the business of ephemeral
tattoos so tattoos that only last year
this is a trend that i'm watching
and uh and we talked about some some of
the pod stuff how we're looking at
youtube
how uh how we're thinking about content
right now and then last but not least
we talk about a couple businesses that
are interesting kind of google
google based businesses i call them
couch cushion businesses because it's
like
these little things in the cracks that
you that you don't really you don't
really
once you go look in the couch cushion
you you find some money but
um you don't really think about these
and some of them are scam some of them
are not we talk about those at the end
yeah in my opinion most of them are
scams and we actually do a breakdown of
them
around the 50th minute of this podcast
so wait till the end and we'll get to it
you'll love it talk soon
did you see did you listen to the
episode that i released
today or today's monday uh it's uh did
you listen to that
no what is it so i consumed like eight
or nine like pretty interesting pieces
of content
last week or and i talked about four or
five of them did you see this guy named
ben moula
who i talked about no who's that okay so
ben moolah i put it in the doc
if you've heard the monday episode today
this is a little bit of a repeat but i
cannot stop watching this guy
he's this big old fat guy like 400
pounds fat because he's probably like
6'3
and he's disgusting he's like smoked
cigarette and he like
looks like he smells and he like always
hits people like on the back real hard
he's just gregarious and in your face
and on the surface he appears like
incredibly dislikable
and cocky and i love him he turns out to
be he seems pretty quite charming and
he's a real estate tycoon down in south
florida
and all he does yeah should i google
this guy ben moolah
yeah all the photos of him like it's
just
it's an immediate turn off but then you
like get into the videos and he's been
he's basically he's like a successful
guy who's now just starting to do
youtube he's probably in his mid-50s and
so
he's not like a youtuber who you know
he's he's does it the right way
where he's successful and now he's doing
youtube very fascinating i can't stop
watching this guy you see what he looks
like
yeah so he's a ben mala is his name so
uh he looks like um what's joe rogan's
friend's name joey
joey diaz he looks like joey diaz does
real estate joey diaz moves to
uh florida and does real estate and he
he wears like gaudy clothes and he's
sitting there smoking marlboros
outside of like a ramada inn or like a
holiday inn that he's about to buy for
20 million dollars
but then he gets into like a 500 000
bentley
and so it's like a really funny
juxtaposition really interesting guy
great advice on real estate in business
nice
very fun youtube you'll have to start
watching this guy he's brilliant
i'm gonna subscribe he's beautiful and
that's actually what we need to do with
our podcast our podcast actually i'm
gonna
i gotta figure out how to do this we
need to become a youtube channel
that happens to have a pod do you know
what i mean yes i know what you mean
uh explain why you say that though so
for one
i'm just i've been a youtube fan for
five years i've been a paying subscriber
and it's my life if it's not on you like
i don't i only watch youtube
um including youtube tv though which is
basically which is tv
but so that's a little cheating but the
discover ability is so good and i've
been watching gary tan's video you know
gary tan
yeah yeah i he's wonderful i don't think
his content is any better than
us but i think it's packaged better than
us for sure and there's a lot to learn
from that
and i think that whenever i see a video
he he does i'm like oh man i totally
could have done that
he just packaged it in such a wonderful
way and the discovery of discoverability
on youtube is significantly better than
podcasts
for sure and um it's just more fun it's
more fun to watch a youtube video and
like i don't know if we have it kind of
skewed because we're able to um
we have youtube red or whatever the
premium thing is called so we were able
to go in the background and basically
make it a podcast whenever we want
i think for a lot of people they don't
pay for that thing uh so that's probably
the main difference but once you pay for
that youtube is just
amazing it's so good yeah we need to
make that shift i'm gonna work on that
this week actually and then one last
quick update
one thing that i'm trying to do that
i've actually done for the last tell me
what you think about this
i've done that for the last five or six
days and i didn't mean to do it at first
but now i don't want to break it
i've walked around twenty thousand steps
a day
for the last about five six days
what are you using to track it well just
my iphone so i was using the health app
then i downloaded like a uh what's it
called the peta
what's the uh anyway i downloaded an app
for it
gotcha and it's awesome a pit pedometer
that's what it is a pedometer
it's awesome have you ever walked have
you ever tried to do like 10 to 15 000 a
day
bro walking that is walking is the new
running no
uh i don't know i've i've never really
liked step counters i always found them
to be like kind of underwhelming
so for example i was like you know like
i've got like a fitbit or whatever the
first one of the early ones of those
were and i hit 10 000 steps
on what i felt like was a very lazy day
and immediately in my head i was like oh
this is for like
old sedentary people and uh i can't use
this
as like a barometer of success for me
but you're really fit and you seem to
care
that you hit 20 000 steps who cares
right isn't like an hour of
intense exercise really what you want
and not 20 000 steps
yes and no so there's pros and cons so
the con
is that for walking the amount that i'm
walking it takes forever
like three hours just three hours of
straight walking
uh some regards that's a pro because
it's fun to be out there and seeing
stuff i'm in a new place exploring so
it's fun
but the pro is also uh so basically if
you run
10 miles that will like if you run 10
miles really fast that will take you 60
minutes
right if you walk 10 miles that's gonna
take you three four hours
but you can actually burn the same
amount of calories doing it which is
kind of interesting
right it takes the same amount of energy
to move your body that distance
but when you walk that much you don't
get that hungry
the problem whenever i run a lot or
whenever i workout a lot i get really
hungry
and i out eat the calories that i
consumed with walking i haven't done
that
i don't i don't i'll eat the calories um
like i don't get starving so it's been
like a really easy way to slim down
anyway i just thought i thought i'd
bring that up you want to get into it
uh yeah let's do it all right which one
you want to go with first
jostens right actually you just on your
random life updates so two things on
that
uh one i don't know where this came from
but over the weekend
i guess you were talking about step
counting and i was just remembering
there's this
little clip i watched on youtube from
the office about when dwight gets a
standing desk i don't know if you watch
the office but
you've never seen this do you i don't
know if you remember this probably not
it's pretty obscure but a deaf dude
i mean i'm like i'm a normal 30 year old
that i've
i could quote every single option right
so so dwight gets a standing
desk and like everybody who gets a
standing desk like it's like awesome for
15 minutes and then you start doing the
thing where like
you're on one foot while you're like
kind of letting the other foot like
chill for a second you're like
stretching out your ankle
and then you're doing the other side and
you're kind of like squatting a little
bit because you're tired
of standing and um and they're basically
like oh wow dwight
at first he's like [__] on everybody
like oh you're sitting you know this is
here he goes
i feel like i'm working in a suicide
cult like because you guys are all
deciding to sit
and um and so then they like turn the
tables on when they know he's getting
tired
and they're like dwight um wow i can't
believe you you've made such a great
decision you're for sure gonna just
do this forever right like there's no
way you go back on this right
and he's like of course not but he's
like secretly like fatiguing really hard
from the standing desk
and uh anyway so they sort of like guilt
shame them and he like ends up with this
um little like like hidden stool in his
pants so that he can like stand uh he
can like sit while he's like pretending
to stand
um and so that reminds me of the step
counting thing which are these like
little
phases that everybody goes through and
where you're just like you know what
i need st i need to i need to hit my ten
thousand steps like i feel like
everybody has this phase of their life
where they like
get into that they buy the device they
do the thing for a bit then they like
get off of it most people do at least
but anyways the reason i say this is
over the weekend i was
supposed to be working because i got
back from this trip and i supposed to be
working and instead i was just watching
a bunch of content i was watching um
you know you know aaron sorkin so i was
like yeah i mean the famous director
yeah writer uh you know kind of like i
don't know if he's producer director or
writer but all three maybe
he he created west wing newsroom uh the
social network movie and he's like
amazing he's brilliant he's known for
his dialogue
so i was just kind of like trying to
branch out trying to learn about what is
how do you even write dialogue what is
that what makes it great why is this guy
so much better than everybody else
so i was watching a bunch of his videos
where he talks about how he does it
and it really made me want to write a tv
show and not to like make a tv show or
make a career out of it but i just want
to write one episode and so i decided
i'm going to write an episode of the
office and i'm going to release it so
that's my challenge for this next 30
days in the next 30 days
i'm gonna write an episode and it's just
gonna be text
and it's gonna be i'm just gonna steal
all the characters from the office and
uh i'm gonna see what i can do and i
think this is gonna be
a lot of fun and i'm gonna release it to
uh anybody who i guess follows me on
twitter on my newsletter or something
like that
my prediction is that it will at worst
be mildly good
i think you're good i think you're good
at it i i think it'll be good right so
like that's the beginner part of it but
i think i could be
i'm also like i think you could i think
i'm like cocky about it i feel like i
can do a good job
did you ever read uh this guy ross wrote
an episode
of silicon valley so this guy he used to
he was an early facebook employee he's
the creator of mozilla
the browser uh yeah or firefox or
whatever uh oh no his name's blake i
think
blake ross yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
he went he he just like for fun
wrote an episode of uh silicon of the
silicon valley hbo show
and it's amazing if if if you've never
read this you should definitely google
this
and read it it's and you if you watch
the show when you read it it's like as
good as a normal episode of the show
it's crazy
and so i was very inspired by that i was
like man what a what a polymath right
like the guy can create a browser early
facebook employee and
is just able to like write a screenplay
basically on his first try which was i
thought incredible
i think you're i think at worst it's
going to be pretty
mildly good i think at best you could
actually have a home run
that's my prediction for how how this is
gonna be and uh so today's july 19th
you now have now you're on the ball well
well no let's do august
the end of august august what is there
twenty day how many days are there 31
days
all right you have to august 31 and then
uh now you're on the hook and in general
i'm thinking about content like
okay content strategy because i'm kind
of like i haven't been posting much on
twitter or anything like that
and i feel like once i started getting
really into twitter i just noticed all
the other
kind of like twitter thread want to be
people like me out there who were just
like doing the same thing
it was really a turn off like i enjoyed
doing it and i enjoyed the results of it
that's what i told you
i hated that everybody else was doing it
made me feel like such a schmuck
uh i felt like you know going to a club
in order and then being like you need to
get a table if you want into this club
it's like oh okay here's my credit card
i guess i'll pay a thousand times what
the bottle costs
like that that was the i felt like a big
chump the first time i did bottle
service and the second time i felt like
a chump in life
was when i was doing twitter threads of
you know generic business advice like
everybody else
and so now i think i'm gonna go i'm
gonna zig and zag the opposite direction
where
i'm just gonna go with like i'm gonna do
a few like what i think are pretty
badass pieces of content that are
extremely challenging for me and if they
flop they flop
but i'm gonna like go ham on them like
i'm gonna you know like i'm gonna write
a rap song or i'm gonna write a
screenplay i'm gonna
like like try to create something that's
like much more
uh intense and possibly awesome i
i think you're right and i'm gonna take
credit because i wrote about this and i
talked on this podcast about this about
six or seven months ago i was like these
threads are killing me
i think longer form blog posts are going
to be coming because everyone's like i
want to start a newsletter i want to get
popular on twitter i'm like all right
great
do that i actually think that there
could be a bigger opportunity
to create a more in-depth blog post i i
have
i had a i have a feeling that this is
kind of what humans are craving at the
mo
or like this is like uh i don't know
what people are craving i mean i think
every type of content will always
release one tenth as much content but
have it be ten times
as good and because of that stand out
from the crowd and have more fun like
because i'm not like
constantly just doing quick hits i'm
like trying to do great work
each time which i think is harder but
more fun maybe something that i've been
thinking about
is related to content because i i ask
myself all the time about how you can
i like repackaging content there's a few
things that i've always been interested
in content so
there's this thing with email so a lot
of people think of email as
like 2 300 words that you can fit in
there or whatever i forget what the
space is it's a certain megabyte space
but you should actually think of it like
i'm just going to make these numbers up
these aren't right it's 150 megabytes
and it just so happens that 250
200 2 500 words is 150 megabytes
but what else can you tell that story
and there's some interesting technology
that i've tinkered with and we've never
gotten to it the hustle but i think we
should
so you can actually host a gif on your
own server
and this might change with apple's new
update but
you can make it so when you send someone
an email you can have like a 30 second
gif on there and a gif is basically a
video with text
which is the same thing as instagram
without sound right it's the same thing
and what about what i've always wanted
to do was to put that on there
and then have a part one and then you
tell at the end of the part one at the
end of the 20-second thing you said
all right now hit refresh and you
actually hit refresh and part two shows
up on your
interesting and i've always wanted to do
things like that like i think that's an
interesting medium i think that could
like be hacked and be
and you could have a really really cool
storytelling yeah i think
so i i would suggest someone try that on
email it is possible like it's
technically possible to do that
and i think that could be really cool
another thing is i've always asked
if you were using twitter for a longer
form blog post what would it look like
if you had a blog post on twitter
that was something like 500 tweets long
right um i've been thinking about like
what would like how do you
hack the how do you hack the rules yeah
that's kind of interesting to me um
anyway
all right let's look at it okay so
that's my content uh i'm putting my
stake in the ground i'm announcing it
publicly
so now i'm committed to having to do it
do you want to talk about let's talk
about stretching labs
or stretching gyms can we talk about
that yeah let's do it because you were
talking about walking
this is actually where i was going to
transition to which is kind of like the
slow exercise movement
so i was working out with somebody who's
i think they're 41
and i was like they're your former
bodybuilder and i was like so
um you know so like what's it yeah
what's what are you working on nowadays
you're trying to get like shredded or
like
build muscle what's the he's like bro
just function
i was like what and you've been talking
about the super mobility training he's
like i have a personal trainer he's like
he's like he pointed at the bench press
and pointed at the like kind of like the
stretching table
and it was like i want to spend more
time there not there
um and i was like interesting and and by
the way i woke up with like massive
shoulder pain today so i'm all about it
right now but
um i noticed there's a trend so i have
this this is my segment called trend
watching i got two trends today
so trend watching the first one is
stretching labs
i never really heard of this but there's
gyms that dedicated to stretching i
don't know if you've ever been to one
one is called yeah one is called stretch
lab it's a franchise i think they have
like
1000 locations in just like five years
or something crazy like that so
definitely like franchising pretty
hardcore nationwide and then there's
another one
um i like the name of this one stretch
relief which is kind of like stress
relief and it's based in new york
and uh it was like a physical place
where then with covered now they do like
online whatever
but i'm kind of into this you so place
you go and you're not it's not yoga it's
not pilates it's like
it's not cycling it's not spin class
it's not uh you know high intensity
training it's another one
stretching and like i just think there's
a market for all of these what do you
think about this you've definitely
thought about mobility and stretching a
lot i am obsessed with stretching
i stretch a ton i download all types of
different apps because i enjoy
trying them all but i stretch on a
consistent basis you're like trying to
do the splits and stuff right
yeah yeah like i work really hard at it
and i like study different types of
stretching
the only type or one of the very few
types of stretching that's proven to
work
i forget exactly what it's called but
basically it's this idea where
if you want to stretch your hamstring um
like in a split
let's say you're doing the front switch
and you want to stretch your hamstring
you actually
need to push down for 10 seconds really
hard so you're
you're you want your hamstring to flex
for 10 seconds and then you release
and that allows you to stretch even
further i don't it does something with
the brain
i don't entirely understand how it works
but i've read a lot of studies and it's
one of the few proven ways and so i've
been obsessed with that
i've gone to stretch lab it's a hundred
dollars i've did it in san francisco and
in austin
totally totally fun totally worth it i
loved it i've been trying to go in
brooklyn where i'm staying now i can't
find a place that does this
i'm completely on board with this i've
also tried to buy different stretching
machines
stretching machines have always
fascinated me because stretching is one
of the few
exercises where you don't actually have
to put that much effort into it and to
get results like someone can kind of do
it to you it's not like with running
where it's just like i gotta put all the
effort like i can just kind of be
numb and someone can do it and so
there's split machines where you can do
side splits and you like sit in this
thing and you crank this wheel and your
legs open up
that's okay that's that's fine but what
i've been looking for is front
machines and different types of
stretching machines i have found close
to nothing and so at my
gym in my house i was thinking about
buying a set of wenches like a winch
like it goes on the be on the
on a jeep to like pull a cord i was
gonna put some on each side of my wall
and create a stretching machine it's
probably gonna look like a sex
machine yeah i was gonna say i think you
could just buy something else and just
use it for a different purpose
i guess you could just buy a sex machine
or like a a reformer
but anyway i'm totally on board with
this i think stretching is good actually
a trend that's going to continue to grow
we've talked about it now for a year now
we've talked about ram
ramwad which is called range of motion
workout of the day
right which is an app that's killing it
we've talked about kelly's star we've
talked about a lot of this i'm totally
on board with stretching yeah stretch
tech um
so i'm keeping an eye on that trend i
have another trend if you're ready to
move on to my
my second trend really quick what
another thing you could do with
stretching so it's stretching in order
to have one of these franchises you
really just need a table
right like nice tables with some bands
another two other things that are really
interesting to me in this space
this the first is um chanting and
breathing work
so i i went to breath work i went to
this one class where i paid 30 dollars
and we just sat there with 30 other
people doing breathing and then
eventually you like chant
i don't understand the science behind it
but i know that i felt great it was fun
it was a good experience for 30 dollars
absolute high i so before
not in a fitness context but one time i
was when i started the sushi restaurant
i was staying
in l.a with the sushi chef his his
mandate was if i'm going to start this
business with you guys
you're going to each come i had three
co-founders there's three of us he said
you're each gonna come you're gonna live
with me
you're gonna work every day at my
restaurant for three weeks each and only
one at a time so you don't have each
other as your little safety net
um and i said okay so you know one guy
went out there a second coming out there
then i went out there
and with me he goes uh it was like you
know kind of a life altering experience
a very wise guy
like kind of like a mr biagi sort of
character for me
and one of the things he did he's like
are you religious and i said no i
i don't believe he said um
he said i'm buddhist i said okay cool do
you know anything about buddhism
no and he goes um all right tomorrow
morning
7 a.m like meet me in the living room
and i was like oh [__] here we go
and uh we went there and so i i didn't
know anything about buddhism
and i still know very little about
buddhism but buddhists have this chant
um that they do as like at least his
practice or his maybe his
sect or whatever it was they have this
one chant it's called namyo harenge kyo
so it'd be
and you repeat that for like one hour
straight you're chanting
just one hour straight and so we start
and i'm just trying to be nice
and i'm like okay i guess i'll just kind
of sit here and like
uh what are these five words what are
they what do i need to know what they
mean no oh they i don't need to know
what do you mean
he was just like just just the sound is
therapeutic and i was like oh that's
interesting because like in hinduism
oh
you hear that in yoga a lot too and
there's something about the vibration of
making this sound
audibly making the sound that by the end
of it you
feel different than you did at the
beginning and so by the end of this
hour i had this like i don't know what
it was it's like a rush of euphoria
basically
uh from chanting and he was like i do
that every morning
it's like a med it's like an audio i
forgot it's called transcendental
meditation or something
it's a form of meditation where you're
not trying to it's like a way to quiet
the mind
by chanting the same thing on loop and
when you quiet the mind
you know you finally you know you get a
sense of peace that's very hard to
achieve otherwise
and after i did that i was like a big
believer in chanting so i've
continued to i'm not buddhist but i've
continued to do this chanting thing on
and off
for like the last 10 years of my life
well and you feel like an idiot doing it
so if i told you to do it without your
guy there
you would feel like a fool and i went
and i felt like a fool too so i went to
one of these classes and you do breath
work which
i don't understand the science behind it
but it felt awesome it felt like i was
it felt like a very mild
uh drug yeah yeah and and
you part of it is chanting and it felt
great and it
when i talked the guy was like yeah this
is like our mvp like i found it on event
right he's like we're thinking about
scaling this and doing
it it was all startuping guy and i was
like dude this greatest business ever
you just need like a space for like 50
people and nothing
else yeah the floor yeah you don't need
anything like i'm in
if you ever like it so so anyway i think
that's interesting i also think
ice baths are interesting i know i've
been noticing on instagram
loads and loads and ice baths we talked
about this company what was the ice bath
company called the barrel company ice
barrel
ice barrel so ice barrel dot co or
something it's um
i know the guy who started it and
they're selling an ice barrel for like
twelve or thirteen hundred dollars
i'm seeing them everywhere i think ice
baths particularly places that you can
go just to take an ice bath i think
are going to get quite popular i think
an ice bath also has a slightly
meditative purpose to it
so the i would add that i would add
those two things to stretching
to look out yeah same uh i just
yesterday i sent
this tick tock this guy is like hey guys
just want to take you through my morning
routine he's like a 60 year old dude
who's just like absolutely chiseled
somehow it's like okay i don't know i
don't know how your body looks like that
a little unnatural but okay was it mark
sisson
no i don't he wasn't like a famous guy
he's just like a guy he's like first
things first i get in the cold plunge
and he's like i get in and i don't do a
lot of like
he's like i just get in that's it and
then he's like and then at three minutes
i get out
i go in the jacuzzi he like hops over
his pool to get to his jacuzzi
he's like and then we're gonna go to the
sauna and like all the comments are like
sir i don't have these amenities at my
house like i don't have all these things
and i think that's the opportunity which
is that when people have these things
they sort of swear by them like our
friend ramone swears by it
tony robbins always talked about this is
how he starts his day goes straight into
the ice plunge then go straight to heat
um
and so there's definitely some like
anti-inflammatory and like sort of uh
neurological effects
waking the body up like this with
something a drastic
physiological change a stimulus and you
don't need caffeine you don't need drugs
to be able to
to get your body to respond and um but i
think there's a problem which is that
they're
so inaccessible so one we talked about
ice barrel and then somebody reached out
a guy who's in my club ltv like uh the
the e-commerce group i have for people
who have an e-commerce store of a
million dollars are up
and he said oh yeah i have this one uh
brand now but i'm starting a new brand
and um his first brand is pretty
successful i think probably 20 30
million his new brand
is gonna do ice baths but it's just a
device you put into any tub
like your normal bathtub and it makes
your bathtub water really cold
and i was like oh that's way better
because i don't want to do like icing
i don't want to buy ice all the time
that's a huge pain in the ass
um and this like iceberg thing like it's
a 2
dollar barrel yeah and you can only you
can't use it if you have an apartment
right and so i'm like well if i already
have a tub and you just let me fill it
up with normal water and i put this
thing in for 10 minutes and it gets cold
like that's awesome actually like now
you just built like a
150 dollar device that does this without
the headache
is it like electronic like you plug it
into yeah i don't know how you put
electric things in water like i'm a
little bit
suspicious well it's like it's like the
opposite of a heating pad
yeah exactly and so it cools water so
i'm very excited about this but if
anybody has like either
ice or sauna technology send it to me so
show me show it to me i really want to
try these i'm very big on this stuff
great uh same so the second for trend
spotting is uh tattoos
yeah ephemeral tattoos specifically so
if you go to ephemeral which is kind of
hard to spell e-p-h-e-r-e-m-a-l
ephemeral dot tattoo check that out so
basically
this is a trend i've been noticing first
there was a company called inkbox that
just made temporary you know temporary
tattoos kind of like
essentially it's a body sticker and uh
and they started doing pretty well they
came out a while ago
and they you know they do kind of like
20 30 million dollars plus in revenue
uh last i had heard which was a few
years ago
and uh so inkbox had done pretty well
and this new one emerald tattoo just
raised 20 million dollars it got my
attention i said what's going on here so
what these guys have is a biodegradable
ink
that you um that can go into even like a
normal tattoo
gun so you got to go to a place so
inkbox is sort of like a sticker you
just put on your skin and then it just
fades away
this is like actually a legit tattoo but
it's a one-year commitment instead of a
you know a 50-year commitment or
whatever like a normal tattoo is
so you go you actually get it and you
know tattooed onto your body and
it degrades after 12 to 15 months it
fades away
and um and so they have like one studio
open in like la
one in like new york and they raised 20
million dollars to do two things one is
to release like colored tattoos because
right now it's just black and white and
the other is like to open more studios
because the way it works is
you put down it's like tesla you put
down a 20 deposit
and that lets you basically book a
reservation at this thing and they have
like a million dollars worth of like
pre-booked reservations at their studios
that they just
are backlogged on and need to need to do
and what i thought was interesting about
this
i was like okay cool it's like some kind
of material innovation
on the material science of the ink but
i like that this can go into a normal
tattoo because i think what
i think the best i think it's sort of
stupid to open up their own uh
you know tattoo parlors maybe you'll do
a few of those but there's 21
000 tattoo parlors in the united states
that's like the same number of like high
schools or in the united states
so there's one one tattoo parlor for
every high school essentially
is that is that a real stat yeah there's
estimated twenty one thousand tattoo
parlors and there's about twenty four
only twenty twenty five percent
i think you're wrong by the way them
having this studio is awesome it doesn't
matter if it makes money or not i guess
what i'm saying is
i think what they should do is they
should sell this to every tattoo parlor
as the hey you want diet coke right you
want the diet tattoo you don't you want
the not lifelong tattoo commitment hey
we sell this thing it plugs right into
our normal thing and we're we have the
staff we have the brick and mortar
locations so i think they could roll out
to 10 000 locations
like this rather than opening up their
own store brick after brick so
anyways i'm pretty excited about this i
think it's kind of a cool idea i uh
i'm gonna sign up i'll go to it they
have a brooklyn one i
was about to get some more tattoos i
would totally do that
right you have a few uh a few
interesting tattoos on your body that
you could talk about
i've got a few bad ones so i have one
two three i've got
four homemade ones and the way that you
you do you the way that you do homemade
ones is you use a sewing needle
and an ink and you just make a ton of
dots i did that when i was like 21
and like partying i was highly
intoxicated i don't entirely regret them
but they look silly
it says like what do you have on your
you have like something on your foot
tattoos no it says wow or mom it depends
and then i have a feet tattoos that say
act now which
are kind of cool they're kind of cool
but yeah like self-administered tattoos
not
every day you see one of those which is
actually uh quite popular is homemade
tattoos it's called stick and poke
when i did it i didn't think that they
were that popular but i think they
actually are quite popular but anyway
this had two business i
i'll 100 sign up for that it looks sign
up for them it it it looks pretty sick
they are black and white so like they do
amazing yeah yeah they look pretty like
like i would get it but if you're like a
cute girl and
you probably don't it's not just that
they're black and white it looks like
they're not like colored in so they're
just like an outline of a shape or at
least that's what i see on the website
it's like a cat but like the cat
it's just like the outline of a cat yeah
i'm into those
ephemeral tattoo i i think you're on
board there
it just opens up the market right like
there's if there's if there's like a
circle that says this is this is a
circle that represents the number of
people
who are willing to get tattoos for life
you say and now there's an option that
you can have a tattoo but it's only
going to last a year and it'll fade away
okay that
circle just got like three times bigger
four times bigger you're just
increasing the size of the adjustable
market for tattoos which is smart
so i think that's cool because you get
to try something for a year that you
could potentially impact the rest of
your life
you know it's always freaked me out like
and and we don't discuss it too much
but or like as a society we accept that
that's normal
buying a home you basically go into it
for like
10 minutes and you're willing to spend
all of your money like every dollar that
you have in 30 years of your life
after like a 15-minute walk-through is
that crazy
is that you actually give you 100-page
disclosure that you can't understand
and then you read some scary stuff in
there and then you're just like i guess
i guess i just live with that termite
issue
i always just thought it was
mind-boggling that you can you you have
to spend
15 minutes for making a decision that
emote for most people it's all their
money and also
it's for 30 plus years of their life
right off of
off a 15 minute walk through that's
always that's always been crazy to me so
this is
that that's well this is good for
tattoos that they get that moment you
want to talk about these uh
these top two things i think yeah so so
i was thinking about
class rings uh or i think um somebody
ben shared a tweet with me that was just
like a meme
it was like uh the the if people want to
know how we get ideas for this so
me and ben just sent his other [__] off
twitter all day and then some of it
you know it's just like a memes but but
i thought started thinking about he goes
some guy coleman oates he goes y'all
remember when a company would come to
your high school and gaslight you into
buying a 400
class ring and you know there's just
like whatever like 100 likes on this
tweet and i just thought it was so funny
and i remember
that happening i remember buying a class
ring and
i lost it i don't know where it is it
was like a waste of money it's so ugly i
was never gonna wear it
uh but i bought it because i was like i
guess this is like the moment i'm
supposed to commemorate
these four years and you know it's now
or never basically to buy this ring
so i like kind of got pressured into
buying it and uh so i started thinking
about this classroom business so let me
tell you some things i discovered all
right so
this guy's kind of like my billy of the
week i got two
very boring business people that i'm
going to feature here so the first guy
is called otto josten and otto josten
is the founder of jostens which is the
number one clash ring maker
and otto johnson he invents the clash
ring basically
so he started this thing in 1897
in ottawa right this is like you know
over 100 years old
and um and so he invents this thing and
basically says okay great we're gonna
have these rings that commemorate the
occasion
and um and so he he creates the
classroom so
what how does this work so basically
high school or college you go to the
school
um at the end of your senior year you
get up-sold into all this stuff
you get up sold into like um you know
shirts yearbooks but the clash ring is
like kind of like one of the more
expensive items 400
500 600 for a class ring sometimes
and um and so i was looking into the
history of this company so basically the
company uh you know
existed for a long time goes public uh
in like 1965 or whatever stays public
for a while
ends up getting acquired by private
equity so it gets acquired by
uh by by something called newell brands
and this is an interesting company to
look into they own
rubbermaid crockpot oster like all these
like home
home appliance companies then they old
like elmer's glue
sharpie yankee candles like all these
brands that we know about they have 10
billion
in revenue across their portfolio brands
and so they had they bought jostens and
they were like look
this company makes about 700 million
dollars a year
but it's been flat uh or declining like
the yearbook and clash ring industry is
sort of like declining five percent a
year
and so it's like ah you know maybe
there's room to turn around so they buy
it for one
1.5 billion i think yeah and then they
try it for a few years can't do anything
with it they sell it to another company
platinum equity
for 1.3 billion so they take a 200
million loss on it
sell the company so still owned by
platinum equity and it's just this thing
that exists
so it started getting me interested like
how does this whole business model work
and what i couldn't find is what's in it
for the schools because the schools
definitely give these people like real
estate
uh on campus or on on premises to sell
this stuff so i wonder if there's a rev
share i couldn't find that that detail
but it got me thinking
how would i compete with this if i was
going to compete with this so i thought
this would be a fun brainstorm so all
right
boring business how would you compete
with this well let let's walk through
how seniors come into this you know i
use did you use josh
johnson's in high school i think i think
we bought jostens yeah uh
so basically if i remember correctly
you're a senior and you get
a magazine do you get a magazine like do
they hand
do they hand like a pamphlet to all
seniors i remember buying it from a
table there was like a table set up with
a little like tablecloth
and on it was a bunch of rings i think
they did have a brochure of like here's
all the different models you can order
try them on and then like you place your
order and you pay the thing and then
it arrives you know months later and
your school
knows who's ordering i think because i
didn't order one i was like i don't this
is nonsense i don't
i don't like high school this much like
i i don't want to ring
and my school came to me and they were
like are you having trouble at home and
i was like no they're like
do you need money to buy the ring we'll
buy it for you and i was like no that's
lovely i i appreciate you guys but i
just think it's stupid
i don't want i don't want a ring and
then they had a ring ceremony
and they just handed me a plain box and
it had like i went to a catholic school
and it had like a
a cross or something in it so that they
just high school you're talking about
yeah so they like had some type of thing
to give me and i was like i appreciate
you guys but i don't want any of this
stuff
but anyway they the school knows who
orders as well
right and so so okay i was thinking
about okay i think there's two models
there's distribution and then there's
product so on the distribution side i
would definitely try to figure out
how do i partner with either the school
themselves
or a sub entity in the school and so um
uh did you invest in that company copper
that i sent you
we passed we passed okay so one of the
clever things that they do i won't go
into their whole playbook but they have
an awesome playbook on how to
there they make it like a debit card
essentially for high school students
and um they grow really well and the
people who were behind it they
created a different product uh for high
schoolers and they had a playbook
basically how do you get high schoolers
on board for your thing and one of the
things that they do
one of the pieces of the playbook is
that they go they partner with one of
the like
organizations in the school so they
can't partner with the school itself too
complicated
but they'll go to like the baseball team
or like the volleyball team and they'll
say hey
you guys need like 500 bucks for your
like uniforms this year
great we'll sponsor it in exchange you
guys help us promote our thing
you guys become an affiliate for every
additional student you bring on board
you get more money for your org and so
it ends up being like you know
a direct ad affiliate deal with with
with the groups and they're obviously
highly motivated because they need to
pay for their stuff
so similarly i guess what i would do is
i would try to for the distribution side
i would partner with either the school
or partner with like you know the band
or like you know some
group in the school and say hey uh if
you guys help us sell this
you get a rev share with this thing so
that's how i would get my foot in the
door then the question is what product
because i think class rings are
incredibly ugly and i think there's
sometimes a good thing about ugly things
because they stand out
and they seem special or unique or
different versus like they're not
ugly they just all look alike like every
class ring
since you know this this thing has been
invented at like 1890 like it's the
exact same thing
if you see someone wearing a class ring
it's like all right al bundy like
you're living in the past here right
like well yeah i'm like you're a [__]
like you're a dork you peaked it's a
dork move right so how do you so first
if you can make it unless you were like
one of the early classes of harvard
like all right i get it right yeah like
unless you won like you know the ncaa
championship
then you wear your championship ring
yeah and even then you should probably
just keep that on a shelf in the house
but like
i think it's okay it's not meant to be
worn necessarily so here's the
opportunities i see so my my best idea
that i came up with and this was like an
hour before we started recording this
my best idea is class sneakers
so i think sneakers are like hot real
estate
and i don't know if you've ever seen
people who make custom sneakers like
either for celebrities or for like
brands
they're awesome they have like a paint
gun or like it's like a tattoo gun
basically
yeah they can like create it's like a
graffiti mural on a pair of air force
ones
so that's the first thing i would try to
do is class sneakers i would try to
basically say great
how do i come up with a base model maybe
it's like converses or air force ones or
something like that
plain plated white shoe and then okay
everybody's graduating right now they're
all let's say class of 21
so i'm gonna have class of 21 and then
i'm just gonna make different color
schemes for the different schools
and uh and then if you pay extra like
you can get your name sort of like
embroidered on the thing or like
whatever your phrase or whatever you
want on the back of it um
and i would basically sell commemorative
class sneakers
that can either be worn or they're just
put on you know put on the wall put it
and put in the
in the house somewhere as a piece which
which shoe which brand and model
i think uh maybe i'm out of touch here
but i like kind of just like
uh like the old school plain white air
force ones i think those are like
yeah that's right one of the best
canvases to to use for something like
this but
simple i don't think it really matters i
think you basically you need some shoe
that
in reality if i was doing this i
probably would like find something
that's shaped like that but it's not
already like a hundred dollars right
because i need to get the shoe for like
twelve dollars
and then i need to do the custom you
know the paint work on it for like
another eight dollars and then i need to
sell that shoe for like 180
or 200 or something like that i think
that's the model here
and i think you could do this with
instagram ads facebook ads and
partnering with school organizations to
do like kind of ref shares
um and i think it could be cool i think
it's like a status symbol so that's how
i would attack
jostens right if they're making 700 800
million dollars a year
on their ugly ass class rings i would
start with class sneakers as my first
idea
yeah i think that's good or so i'm
looking at i'm looking at it dude they
sell some ugly ass [__] i cannot believe
this business is in place
and here's the take here's the takeaway
here is that
once you get locked into some to a
certain contract
yeah i would actually phrase it like
it's hard to [__] up or default if
you're the boring default
it's so good such a good position to be
in and a lot of times when i think of
like when
we think of entrepreneurship and we
think of starting stuff we think how can
i be innovative how can i be new
in reality in order to make a lot of
money it's how do i get locked into this
to to the point to where like it's gonna
be a pain in the ass to
go anywhere else and that's the takeaway
here
i'm looking at johnson's they they
started you said in in
in 1897. yeah okay so if you started
something 124 years ago
and you are still in cahoots with these
high schools this is significantly
better than any enterprise sas
company this is significantly better
than a newsletter
do this when i think of this is idiot
proof
jostens is idiot proof i used to say
that uh
real estate has the highest uh number of
low iq millionaires
jostens is is the the best example of
that i've ever seen
i love this company and i think that
when i start stuff
that's that's what i should think of uh
how can i just create something that
people buy
forever and i have to innovate on the
product zero
that's exactly what they've done the
best example of this that we came up
with that we had on the podcast was the
uh
the workplace compliance poster that you
have to have
for like the hr or safety or whatever
work the poster every office has in the
break room
um that poster you just have to buy
every year it's like 100 or something
and you just have to get it every year
otherwise you're out of you're like out
of compliance you're like out of code
and uh you know zero employees just sort
of like an auto renew where i send you
this like
one cent poster for a hundred dollars is
like such a beautiful
beautiful business and in fact i almost
want to just come up with like another
compliance poster actually this is my
next idea here
live on the podcast what's another like
[__] ass compliance poster that i
could make
that i could sell to every company like
maybe it's like something with like the
modern day woke stuff like it's about
like
you know anti her openness and her
anti-harassment and like pronouns and
like everything it's just like a
reminders
of like how to not be canceled so so
it's basically there's like a reminders
poster
that gets updated every year with the
latest cancellation policy
and uh you just need to make it seem
like a totally boring company uh thing
and you just sell this to every age you
said send it to them once and then you
like get them on file to like have this
in
their you know restrooms every year or
something like that
if you work for a company like this like
one like what you're describing or
jason's
so it looks like on glassdoor they've
got three thousand employees
dude if you're working [__] dude you're
asleep you've been able to sleep for 65
straight
years what do you make up there in
hibernation what are you like
why do they even need employees that's
what like i'm looking through this like
what's the point of having a person do
this
like you could fire most ev all your
people and just build stuff that it
automates it and you simply have sales
people that just try to like
sell stuff but like you don't need
anything i i i'm looking at their class
door i'm like what on
they have a thousand to five thousand
people i thought it said three thousand
in
another place i don't even know what you
do like what what do you
if you're the ceo of this company what
do you do every day are you like hey
this week we're gonna try this it's like
no you're just keeping the lights on the
whole time and i'm okay with that it
sounds like i'm criticizing it i'm not
what the [__] do you mean if you work
for this company has the little mini
pudding green in their office you know
that little putting green of a one-hole
putt-putt golf you could put in your
office michael burris yes michael burr
he has one of those in office he's
probably listening to this right now
looking at the putting green and being
like god damn it uh those guys are wrong
about everything but they're right about
the damn putting green i gotta get rid
of this thing
this is what i i want to start something
like this where you just have to do no
work
ever i mean i just just undercut them
right so i think i think you could
advertise on facebook and instagram and
be like hey
seniors don't get ripped off by jostens
same ring half the price yeah this
amazes me
i have none of the employees and i'm
going to drop ship this out of china so
like
hey don't get ripped off by josten's
that's that's my ad creative
again somebody wants to do this just
keep me up i just want to hear how this
plays out if you end up doing this
just advertise against this all right so
this is crazy right so i want to talk
about the second one
this paint one this is interesting by
the way i sent you an instagram there's
another person
who's trying to compete with them and
they're just making a classroom that
doesn't look tacky
uh so that was also like one model which
is like these rings look cool it's
someone called j
hannah or something like that that's her
instagram jay.hanna
and it looks like they got meaning
meaningful traction
yeah these are clinic clash these are
clash rings there's only four it's like
they just stand for like kind of like
earth wind fire and ice or something
like that but they're just kind of clash
rings with the year
and uh they just look better they look
cool when you wear them so that's
another way you can go about this
all right um here's you wanna know about
here's another company that you're gonna
be mind blown about
do you know what the pantone color chart
is
the pantone matching system i googled it
googled it and i
see things that i recognize like a like
a color wheel
yeah okay so here's here's the story
here's the story you need to know okay
so
um there's a guy frank who sent this to
me on twitter so shout out to frank
uh he's got like an egg profile on
twitter but he listens upon he just goes
hey
pantone this has got to be a huge
business these guys sell this freaking
color book for 500
and so i said wait i have one of those
color books on my desk
what the what's there's a business
behind this and sure enough okay so
here's the back story
uh there's this guy okay so otto josten
was our first you know billy of the week
lawrence herbert is my second uh
lawrence herbert basically they oh
these guys they owned a print company uh
print a printing company
and they got tired of the fact that like
they had all these inconsistencies in
colors right so you would try to just
describe a color or it's blue color but
like which shade of blue
and then all these different inks they
were trying to keep track of a name or
whatever
and they said screw it we're going to
create
the global standard for colors so all
they did was
they took every single shade of color
and they put a number on it
and they gave this to every like
manufacturer
fashion house architecture firm like
you're picking the colors for your
curtains
what pantone color you're gonna use uh
you're picking you know the color of
your fabric for your clothing brand what
color you're going to use you're you
know
uh crazy like ben jerry's uses the color
chart for
they have a quality assurance uh group
that basically looks at the brownies
that are going to go in the brownie
fudge bites or whatever
and if the brownie color is between
you know brown 690 and brown 669
then it's good it's properly baked and
if it's under or over it's like too
baked or it's under baked
so they just hold this up and they look
at the brownie and they say does this
match this color or not and so
this thing is used ubiquitously so they
created this pantone color system the
matching system
it's like 2 500 colors they make over
100 million dollars a year
just sending out this little brochure
this little pamphlet there's a booklet
with all the colors in it and everybody
buys these things we have one here
because when we need to communicate with
our manufacturer for our brand
we have to tell them hey use pantone
color 506c or whatever it is
so they know that we want that specific
shade of blue
how did this uh product start so so the
guy
owns the printing company decides to
create the pantone matching system
and the number one way they got the word
out was this marketing stunt like we
we talked about um michelin star and we
talked about like that that
that system so they started coming out
with color of the year
so they just they would make they put a
ton of money and effort effort behind
color of the year so
2016 rose quartz 2015 marsala
you know 2012 tangerine tango is the
color of the year 2011
classic honeysuckle color of the year so
they they they do this big marketing
blitz around what is the color of the
year
and in order to come up with it they
have this hush-hush process where they
invite 12 like trend spotters to their
office
and then they each give presentations
and kind of like debate around like
culture and where the where society is
moving
and then they come out and they're like
honeysuckle is it and then they
immediately blitz the market with that
they send that to all the like fashion
houses ad agencies
and then they start using that in their
campaigns and they start you'll start
getting emails which is like oh buy our
thing
it's got the color of the year this is
honeysuckle the color of the year for
this dress
and so brands start using that for their
own marketing and so it started
spreading that way
and so they sell these booklets for like
you know eighty-five dollars up to five
hundred dollars these booklets
and then every year they launch like a
hundred new colors so you gotta get a
new booklet with all the new colors in
it it's like the dictionary
and uh i just thought this was amazing i
didn't know there was even a
company behind us and it makes over a
hundred million dollars a year all right
i'm gonna blow your mind all right we're
gonna we're gonna build office go to
wgsn.com so wgsn.com do you see that
yeah i think you've told me about this
one these are the trend trend makers
right they have like a ascent of the
year or something like that
no colors it's colors as well exactly
what you described
um they do almost exactly that except
except
it's a it's really like one or two
reports a year
but it's a subscription service and they
sell to businesses and they're a public
company so i can look up their revenue
so their revenue last year was 90 uh
90 million euros i think this is a euro
so 100 yeah 100 million dollars
and it's been doing a hundred million
dollars or it's been doing around that
forever so it's currently researching
reports basically
but it it it's we could dumb it down we
had the founder of david's tease on here
and he was talking about how he uses a
brand he he
used to pay for stuff like this and i
remember asking him like is it just
[__] or is this like
why are you buying this like i don't
know how much this report is like
thousands of dollars for this
thousands and thousands he was like oh
totally worth it like that's how we got
the new
like flavors and fragrances for the news
teas every year
i was like wow okay interesting so it's
called wgsn
wgsn.com and to dumb it down
starbucks who will buy a hundred
thousand uniforms or a hundred
or [__] 10 million coffee sleeves
they want to know which color for
christmas what
shade of red is going to be interesting
enough or
um if we're buying these uniforms uh
for this one this promotion which color
is the right color
by the way the starbucks red thing my
wife
loves starbucks she goes starbucks
anytime she can and she literally looks
forward to the red cup moment where they
switched the cups
and like it's like it's like an
emotional thing almost it's like
um it's basically like oh [__] like
like the season has changed christmas
time is here i get these warm fuzzy
feelings and part of that i associate
with is the red cups
which i just found to be like crazy that
anyone cares
well yeah it just means that it's winter
time um and so this company called wgsn
companies pay i think it's 18 grand a
year
and they also have someone you could
talk to so you can ask them a question
it's called the that's what they call
their advisory service they just like
you you ask people questions but then
they also so i believe the way the
business works is they
they do two things they look at loads of
different data on which what's
what type of color is selling well and i
imagine it's just someone else's data
the second thing is they survey people
and so they'll survey like
people who they deem as experts and they
ask them questions and then they create
this like
survey response of like all right here's
according to all the experts this color
these colors for this type of niches are
going to be the colors that you're going
to use in the future
and if you know if you have a company
that's not like
growing that much but it's worth 90
million euro a year
in subscription revenue i mean that's
like a three four five hundred million
dollar a year company or a company
that i think makes like 30 million
dollars a year in profit
only off colors and this is the second
one in a few minutes that we've named
colors are very interesting and by the
way these guys the pantone guys they
then partner with some of the firm to
come out with the
so the pantone became has become the
universal like
language of color how do you describe
color to somebody you describe it the
pantone chart
uh and by the way the reason why there's
like a science there's a bit of a
mechanical reason why so like
a normal printer if you use a printer i
think a normal like household printer
will
has this thing called cmyk if you've
ever seen that like capital cmyk what
does that mean it's like
cyan magenta magento
yellow and black or something and
basically you can mix those four colors
and you can make a whole bunch of
combinations of colors just using those
four
it's like rgb for tvs and um
but pantone if you have a pantone
machine then the pantone machine
basically has like
18 base colors and so you can mix and
you can mix
because it's 18 specific base colors you
can create all these really specific
shades
so when you give somebody the color it's
not just so that their eye knows what it
is except they can punch it into the
machine
and create that specific pigment or that
specific ink or that specific printed
color on top of whatever it is
so there's like you know they needed
something like that which is pretty cool
um but anyways these guys partnered with
somebody to come out with like
the pantone of taste and the pantone of
smell also right how do you describe a
fragrance
well how how do you do this and so they
partnered with some company they they
also tried to own that space
and which i just think is awesome to be
like kind of the global authority
i agree naming of a color and somehow a
private company owns that
which is insane it's like owning you
know the periodic table or something and
we were talking about you called it
boring i think this is fun
i think this is actually kind of fun
this i don't know if i would want to do
it all the time but this is like a fun
thing because you can kind of shape
culture
i mean we were talking about that red
that starbucks
like you you or like the coca-cola red
or the fact that
um do you know that coca-cola invented
santa claus pretty much or like the
way that we the way that we envision
santa claus i don't want to go too much
off the cuff because i didn't actually
research this but
i'm a i like old stuff like and i like
american history
um and so i've read stories about this
but like the modern day
santa with like that red suit fat guy
who's got a white beard that's a
coca-cola invented that
oh [__] we need to go deep on that one
we should go back okay uh
all right so i'm gonna call this
business i discovered this business the
hard way so we
were traveling we left something at you
know the tsa security checkpoint where
you're like putting all your stuff in
the bins or whatever
and uh we left something in there and so
we get on the plane my wife's like
no where's that thing oh don't worry i'm
sure we can just sort of call them or
like
you know file and file a report and are
you trying not to say what it is
uh what the item yeah oh it was i mean
it's just like a
baby stroller bag thing uh you know it's
like 150
item but like not you know whatever
nobody it doesn't matter what it is left
an item there
um we so i'm like okay let me google
like just
hey item left tsa las vegas airport
and um and the first thing that comes up
is thing called insta file get you
follow follow your claim you get your
thing back i click it
and it's like oh just tell us what your
item is and we'll get it back to you
don't worry about it and then you go
through the flow and then it tries to
charge you 29 dollars at the end i'm
like okay whatever
oh and as i'm doing this oh so i go
through i follow this i'm starting to
follow this thing and i start to get my
spidey spin sensors tingling i scroll
down
and i see you know is the file is not
associated with any airport tsa or
anything like that i'm like oh
what is this pretty interesting business
so so first
i think it's clever a clever move right
i call these couch cushion businesses
it's like finding change in the couch
cushion
it's like these little cracks in the
system where you can just like slip
right in and create a business so
of course people are gonna be losing you
know one out of a thousand people are
gonna lose something in tsa
what are they gonna do they're gonna
google it and these guys are the top
ranking result
for that uh for every airport i think
and so
um they just all they do is filing a
claim is actually free what they do is
they just rank at the top
they get you to pay for it and then they
go file the claim on your behalf and
this forwards your they just forward
your report to them
and then they forward you their response
and it's like i mean a scam
it's not a scam it's it's like a kind of
a managed service
the part it's very misrepresentative and
so you go read the reviews people are
very angry at them i don't get angry
about this sort of thing i actually
i'm like oh clever clever you've found a
way to like
you know capitalize on this um and you
know there is some value added service
because again there is like an agent in
the middle
i don't know how much that's what i'm
saying it's my it's
it's very technically it's not a scam
it's just misleading
it depends if they're actually better at
if they actually save you time or money
uh or like you know increase your odds
of getting your thing back if they're
really just forwarding your report and
then forwarding their email back to you
then there's like zero value add
but if they are actually like you know
filing it right following up
for you calling and getting the answer
then great uh you know that's dude i
can't find
anyone online who works at this company
yeah you can't find the owner you can't
find the about page
and that's why i'm like okay yeah and
you know probably more towards scam
but anyways i just thought this is
fascinating how many different
businesses are there like this there's
probably a ton of different business
like this that are just like these
really hyper-specific scenario searches
that um that you can rank number one for
and then when you do
i bet you kind of print money i bet you
this business is you know profitable
seven figures business just off this one
uh
this one thing like mugshots.com or
mugshot website
what is that to look up mug shots yeah
you've never tried to look at someone's
mug shot
oh my god it's littered with scams so
google
like uh find mugshot california
or like you know like imagine like what
imagine a friend gets arrested and
you're trying to find a mug shot google
whatever you're going to google
uh all right so i'm seeing a bunch of
ads four ads at the top right let me
find mug shots for free
it looks like a search bar i can search
their name
and it goes finds the public records and
i'm guessing it's going to charge me
something at some point
crazy right yeah it's pretty wild so a
lot of these mug shots that they get
they're just public so if you know where
someone gets arrested you can just go
not all counties are that way but you
can just go to like um
uh san francisco or so that would be
like alameda county uh mugshots and you
can actually go to the website
and they just like and they just
aggregate it but they have super super
slick onboarding ways to like
uh get you to give them money and the
website's super optimized right like
this
right next to the search bar it says
norton security and mcafee secure
the why do i what does that have that's
a virus scanning protocol what does it
have to do with
me typing in someone's name to search
for them like but it's just like these
random ass trust building badges
right next to the search bar just to get
me to do this for free yeah so it's
not actually gonna be free it's
incredibly scammy and anyway
it's very similar to what you're
describing we can actually do a i'll
actually do a breakdown about this uh
very soon um maybe next week i'll do a
breakdown on this business
historically incredibly scammy probably
you could own the person who
who can own one of these businesses and
make like 10 15 million dollars a year
profit although you got to like you know
live this shitty life where like you're
just kind of a piece of [__] scamming
someone
but it's like it's crazy fascinating um
that these mugshot businesses i think
they crush
yeah so do you know who naveen jane is
yes so he's like a billionaire guy now
but
he the way that he became a billionaire
he's kind of done a good job of
rebranding himself as this like
inspirational tony robbins guy
yeah but he owned a bunch of scammy
businesses and i believe
some of them were ponzi schemes that he
took public so what was it a ponzi
scheme i don't think exactly but
basically during the dot-com boom
uh there was a company called infospace
and he was the ceo of infospace
and i don't know the full story i should
look it up but i remember reading it
because i met his son his son
uh this guy ankur jane a really
interesting guy and you know like
he's he was kind of like i was sort of
like why is this kid so like
polished why do i feel like when he's
talking to me he's talking like on cnbc
or something like that like
this i got this like politician vibe
from him and so i was looking him up
like oh he's the son of this billionaire
and they you know grew up you know in
the same neighborhood as like you know
whatever bill gates and other guys
and then somebody had told me somebody
was like yeah his dad's kind of
controversial
so why is that and he said he started
info space took it for space public
and then before infospace crashed in the
dot-com crash
he had like i know sold a bunch of his
stock he ended up doing great all of his
employees you know lost their kind of
like
the company went under but he ended up
doing very well that's the like long and
short of it now
i don't know if it was like you know
some kind of like underhanded stuff i'm
not sure but
definitely there's like a long kind of
like report that it's pretty hard to
google for it because i think he's like
scrubbed it
but you can find it from the old like
seattle times or something like that
uh but then he started another company
that also had controversy
called intellius and intellius is the
one you're thinking about
and um intellius i think it sold uh
like for over a hundred million dollars
but what it was is sort of like in the
uh
it was a so it's a way for people to
peruse criminal records and conduct
background searches online
but the way the way it worked if you
look if you google like intellius scam
or intellius shady
you'll see that like it basically looked
like one of those like free credit
report
like kind of services or it's like oh
you just type your name you'll get your
your data your report
and there's like this tiny checkbox
that's like you know
you know you agree to pay 19.99 for the
rest of your life if you do this
and like and so that's how they were
making a bunch of their money was they
were just taking aggregating public
records
making them a little more searchable and
they had this sort of like
hard to see subscription that you were
paying for at the end of it
uh maybe i i don't know exactly you must
have entered your credit card so it
can't be that hard to see but there was
a bunch of controversy around intellius
i remember
yeah yeah yeah
now he's got like this company moon
express that's like sending rockets to
the moon and like
and now he's got something called volume
it's like imagine a world where illness
is
optional and it's like you know trying
to save the world save the planet type
of guy and
if you hear him talk he's extremely
charismatic um
as people who who tend to you know run
schemes tend to be
and so he's um i don't know i i don't
know i don't
really have an opinion myself i just
know that there is some controversy
around this guy
but i find him to be a pretty
fascinating character i find him very
interesting to hear when he talks
very inspirational type of speaker and
now is doing these kind of like big
picture elon musk type of things
but got his start doing something much
less savory
we should have someone come on and talk
about some of the stuff i didn't realize
that
i i knew what atelieus was but whenever
i do these background checks i like
doing background check stuff it's fun
have you ever like
like don't you ever do it to like see
like have my parents ever been arrested
let's find out
um no i had never do anything like that
but i'm also not like
ancestry.com or 23 of me i think there's
a lot of people who are just like
big into like self-exploration kind of
like my past
other people's past things like that and
uh
i i just haven't done that a ton well so
that's me
so i understand a lot of people i think
most people like answers.com is a huge
business
so i think um anyway i think this yeah i
i i didn't realize i i thought that
someone could make 10 or 20 million
dollars a year from this but now that i
remember intellius i think was doing
hundreds of millions from this
yeah i ran into some another business
like this that was looking for people's
addresses so when we had that like i
i came on the pod i talked about
somebody was stealing from us and we
knew who they were we're gonna find them
and send the cops to their house and
stuff like that
well i needed to find somebody's address
and so i started basically if you have
like a couple pieces of information
a name a phone number stuff like that
there's these like
websites that will come up they'll say
hey yeah we'll give you this we have a
huge database of
everyone's address just put in their
info and then you get like three steps
down the funnel it's like
oh to unblur the address you gotta pay
9.99 in a month
it's like why do i need this monthly i'm
not doing this every month but okay sure
i really want this address
and like they're just like i bet you'll
forget to cancel this and it's like a
slogan
a lot of times with those services you
can do a good enough job of if you
actually cross-reference a ton of them
you can actually find the name on
blurred because they'll show you three
like
pieces i'll show you like three possible
options and like the third one which is
likely it is is blurred but then you
could like do some weird like
triangulation and figure out which one
it is it's kind of interesting i've done
it before as well yeah this is like sort
of the dark parts of the internet and
all they're doing like you said is
they basically take stuff that's public
record or they take
guesses and then they um they aggregate
it and put a fancy kind of search bar
and they just do a good job of ranking
and google are paying for for google
adwords and that's their business model
but uh
you know i don't know too much about
these i've never thought about doing a
business like this but
when i run into them as a customer i'm
like hmm what's underneath this how the
heck does this thing work
me too fascinating me too and
my mug shots is a classic i'm gonna do
some interest in a mug shot i'm gonna
tell
jake to do to look at mug shot stuff
that's a great one
um all right i think that's the episode
right yeah let's wrap it
i feel like i can rule the world
travel never looking back